six months ago we were children this is
who we are now how would you describe
this show it's like a modern-day Lord of
the Flies it's about a group of people
who it looks like they're in a parallel
universe but nothing is as it seems
and my character put omalley and she's
like a reluctant leader of this new
society as you have seen and she has to
take control of this power this place
looks like home it's not there's nothing
we're all alone a bunch of kids get lost
in a town that's their own but not quite
their own and they work to discover it
out and it's very interesting to watch
them do so oh my and now he's alive we
just want to be with you home this is
sort of that Lord of the Flies a young
group of people trying to figure out
what it means to be a society and
survive without guidance everything that
kept us safe is gone there's no
civilization here not until we start
what I described the society as I mean I
guess it's a kind of modern-day take on
Lord of the Flies you know like a bunch
of kids and it's based on this kind of
old mythology of the Peter Piper thing
about this guy who kind of stole the
children of a community because of their
sins of the parents right so essentially
these kids are lost in this town
completely like as if plucked out of you
know the universe and put somewhere so
it's I guess it's about its
coming-of-age definitely in a lot of
ways it's also quite political in the
way the kids deal with their problem and
who's supposed to take power
what kind of people I guess a liable or
wanting to take power what did you have
- I'm not going to ask for power we're
going to take it one of the coolest
scripts I've ever read I think that it's
it's about a group of kids who end up in
a town that looks just like their town
except there are no adults in sight and
it's really an exploration of I mean who
are you when there's no order in place
what kind of person are you gonna be not
afraid of you you should be this show is
very edgy it's a modern take on the Lord
of the Flies and really has a lot of
deep meaning based on the political
state of the world today the show is
really deep has a lot of twists motional
it's heartfelt it's going to keep people
on the edge I think people are gonna be
wondering what the hell they would do if
they were put in this situation and it
is not just for teens it is for
everybody there's enough darkness at the
adults to be into it and then like
enough to teen drama that you know from
jail fans would love it - sir it's kind
of everything I think there's nothing on
Netflix like it right now
it's totally different essentially a
modern edgy take on Lord of the Flies is
a pretty good description show it is fun
it's very exciting I think each episode
gives you a little something you can
take away from it I was telling somebody
else you know I want to leave somebody
with a little bit of experience that's
the whole part point of cinema to me is
to give to give people something take
them out of reality and let them
experience something different for a
while and each episode I feel like get
you a little bit of that modern take on
the Lord of the Flies
um survival of the fittest rebuilding
and remaking of politics and
teenagers juicy fun very smart very
provocative it gets the people going
cannibal close commission that's what
I'm afraid don't I